Estimate the solution to 582,205
plus 610,859, rounding
these two numbers to the
nearest thousand.
So we going to round each of
these numbers to the nearest
thousand and then add them,
and that'll give us an
estimate to this solution.
So let's do each of
these numbers.
So if we start off with 582,205,
we want to round to
the nearest thousand.
So you go to the thousands
place, and you go one place
below that.
If that's 5 or greater,
round up.
If it's less than
5, round down.
This is less than 5.
The 2 here is less than 5,
so we want round down.
We are going to round it down,
so it's going to be 582,000.
We're just going to round
it down to 2,000.
We're going to get rid of
all of this 205 here.
582,000 when we rounded it down
to the nearest thousand.
Now, we have 610,859.
Same drill.
Go to the thousands place.
That's the 0 right there.
Look one place below the
thousands place.
This is that 8 right there.
If this is 5 or greater,
you round up.
Less than 5, round down.
It is 5 or greater.
8 is greater than 5.
Or it could even be 5 and we'd
still around up, so we're
going to round up in
this situation.
We're going to round up, so we
end up with 600, and instead
of 610,000, we're rounding
up to 611,000.
We've rounded the two numbers
to the nearest thousand.
Now we're ready to add.
So let's add them.
Let's add the two numbers.
0 plus 0 is 0.
2 plus 1 is 3.
8 plus 1 is 9.
5 plus 6 is 11.
If there were more places here,
we would carry the 1 in
the tens place.
But there isn't, so you can
just write an 11 here.
And so we are left with-- put
a comma every third digit--
1,193,000, which is
our estimate.
And the whole reason why this
is useful is if someone were
to give these numbers to you and
you had to do it in your
head, it's hard to add these
whole numbers, but you might
be able to do 582 plus
611, knowing
everything isn't thousands.
So it allows you to do things
in your head a little bit
easier when you round, and then
you estimate the sum of
the rounded numbers.